la carrière du Maurice de Dieudonné
décolle dans les années 90 avec son
compère de l'époque Élie Semoun bonjour
monsieur mais quelques années plus tard
Dieudonné enchaîne les polémiques
l'homme tient alors des propos jugés
antisémites et négationnistes sont
spectacle fait l'objet d'une
interdiction et il est condamné à
plusieurs reprises par la justice j'ai
dérangé beaucoup de monde et je vais
continuer à le faire mais aujourd'hui
dans une lettre ouverte publiée par
Israël magazine Dieudonné tient pour la
première fois à présenter ses excuses
envers la communauté juive j'ai parfois
été trop loin et fait preuve d'outrance
de provocation déplacée pour toutes ces
fautes et excès je demande pardon alors
lettre d'excuse événement de Dieudonné
peut-on le pardonner
merci merci à vous d'être là je vous
remercie Emmanuel Ludo qui est devenu
nous voir avocat Dieudonné merci d'être
là merci beaucoup je crois que vous
connaissez Jean-Marie Bigard
je sais vous êtes déjà venu pour ce
sujet et on a André Darmon avec nous
patrons de Israël magazine qui est là je
croyais que vous êtes à côté de Mathieu
d'or mais non je crois que vous étiez
les deux de ce côté c'est fou cette
décision vous allez nous dire quand vous
avez pris la décision de de publier
cette lettre Israël magazine déjà c'est
c'est quoi Israël magazine c'est alors
c'est un mensuel qui existe depuis 25
ans d'accord
comme son nom l'indique pas c'est en
français donc je suis un je suis un
franco-israélien je suis les je suis
même à part égo qui a qui a fait son
comme on dit son Allia il y a une
quinzaine d'années et puis qui s'est
lancé dans le journalisme parce que
c'était ma passion donc il serait ma
cuisine existe depuis 25 ans et on
s'intéresse bien évidemment à tout ce
qui se passe en Israël mais aussi à la
communauté au comité juive du monde et
en particulier celle de celle de France
alors je vais vous lire la lettre de
Dieudonné dans un instant en entier
juste comment ça s'est passé qui vous a
contacté pour pour Francis Lalanne qui
m'a contacté avec lequel j'étais en
contact de contact depuis que depuis
longtemps Francis et qui et qui m'a
parlé de ce revirement de ce repentir de
cette repentance de Dieudonné il faut
savoir qu'avec Dieudonnée j'avais un
passé pour ne pas dire un passif parce
qu'il y a 10-15 ans c'était on s'était
j'ai dit on était pas très loin de
d'aller devant les tribunaux parce que
bon comme beaucoup j'avais pas tout à
fait apprécié tout ce qu'ils étaient et
quand Francis que je connais bien que
j'estime m'a parlé de ce revirement
assez exceptionnel je dis oui pourquoi
pas c'est tous une démarche j'allais
dire spirituelle que journalistique
c'est pas du tout un scoop c'est vrai
que ça fait le buzz mais ce n'est pas le
but et je pense que quand quelqu'un vous
demande pardon quand quelqu'un demande
dans un son mais juste il faut l'écouter
quoi
j'ai préféré je le vois demain d'accord
je l'interview demain pour une chaîne
franco-israélienne à plus que vous
connaissez bien sûr puisque il y a des
MP je crois qu'il va passer sur
exactement dans sa version TPMP
donc je l'ai pas je l'ai pas vu j'ai
préféré vous avez hésité à publier la
lettre vous n'êtes pas totalement parce
que d'abord je lui je suis ni juge je
suis pas un juge je suis pas un
confesseur je suis et bon ça faisait ça
faisait quelques années que j'avais pas
eu de contact avec lui donc je ne savais
pas très très bien où il se situait donc
j'ai pris le temps de la réflexion et
j'ai dit j'ai précisé à Francis que je
vais le publier parce qu'encore une fois
quelqu'un qui qui réclame qu'on l'écoute
qui réclame qui dit je me suis trompé
j'ai sauté mais à culpa il faut je crois
l'écouter et je crois qu'il faut suivre
le menteur jusqu'à la porte en espérant
que Dieu nous donne ne nous demande pas
donc oui j'ai pris du temps pour j'ai
pris la nuit une nuit de réflexion oui
tout à fait alors je vous dirai la
lettre
je demande pardon cela fait plusieurs
décennies que je ne m'étais pas que je
ne m'étais exprimé dans un média
officiel je ne pensais plus le refaire
un jour mais c'est ainsi le temps passe
il n'épargne aucune de mes certitudes
cela fait 35 ans que j'exerce la
profession du Maurice bien plus qu'un
métier cette fonction fut pour moi une
véritable passion un sacerdoce pour
lesquels j'ai consacré l'essentiel de
mon existence et de mon énergie au
détriment souvent de mon entourage le
plus proche et notamment de mes sept
enfants que je n'ai quasiment pas vu
grandir
je saisis l'occasion qui m'est donnée
ici pour leur demander pardon et de leur
redire à quel point je les aime je tiens
également à demander pardon à toutes
celles et ceux que j'ai pu heurter
choquer blessé au travers de certaines
de mes gesticulations artistiques je
pense notamment à mes compatriotes de la
communauté juive avec lesquels je
reconnais un peu mon maître laissé aller
au jeu de la surenchère c'est vrai j'ai
parfois été trop loin et fait preuve
d'outrans de provocation déplacée pour
toutes ces fautes et excès je demande
pardon mon ambition était de faire rire
tout le monde et la communauté juive
fait partie de mon monde
je n'ai pas réussi à la faire rire et je
le regrette bref mon âge ma santé
m'invite aujourd'hui à préparer ma
retraite au Cameroun sur la terre de mes
ancêtres aussi j'aspire à quitté la
scène en paix en paix avec moi-même en
paix avec les autres dans un respect
réciproque et sincère je veux apporter
ma pierre à l'édifice de la
réconciliation dans un contexte de
tension générale exacerbique plus que
plus que jamais je suis persuadé que le
rire et la dérision auront un rôle à
jouer dans la restauration du lien de la
fraternité qui s'est rompue je suis un
être imparfait mais sincère qui cherche
à réparer ses erreurs et c'est faute
merci du fond du cœur d'avoir bien voulu
me lire et d'avoir accepté de me publier
entendons-nous bien je ne me cherche
aucune excuse aucune circonstance
atténuante car nul n'en a lorsqu'il peut
constater qu'il la nuit à son prochain
je demande tout simplement pardon pour
le mal que j'ai pu faire
même sans le vouloir Dieudonné aime la
balle alors voici la lettre qui a publié
donc Israël magazine aujourd'hui c'est
une lettre ou pas tous de l'être
événement parce que c'est vrai qu'on s'y
attendait pas du tout vous allez nous
dire ce que vous en pensez vous bien sûr
ici autour de la table mais je voudrais
d'abord m'adresser à l'avocat Dieudonné
maître Emmanuel Ludo
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé Dieudonné
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui a fait qui
s'est dit il faut que je mets une lettre
d'excuse je sais que j'avais eu rumeur
voilà que ça faisait longtemps que ça
qu'il était dans ce dans un dans une
démarche de pardon ça fait deux trois
mois que j'entends ça
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé en fait
Emmanuel
il y a une prise de conscience qui date
non pas d'aujourd'hui mais de plusieurs
années
c'est
la certitude qu'il a que
on peut pas rire de tout d'accord voilà
on peut pas rire de tout que le sujet de
l'antisémitisme est un sujet
extrêmement sérieux et d'une gravité
absolue
et il a pris conscience que voulant
faire rire il a fait souffrir
que voulant cicatriser il a blessé
et lorsque je l'ai rencontré c'est il y
a quelques mois ce que je le connais
depuis longtemps mais je l'ai eu en face
de moi il y a peu de temps septembre
dernier et que il a mis sur la table ce
qu'il voulait faire
c'est moi je reconnais qui lui est dit
que ça pouvait pas prendre la forme
d'une demande de pardon comme ça à la
volée au cours d'un spectacle c'était un
sujet tellement sérieux qu'il fallait
que ça soit préparé et préparer une
manière minutieuse cette lettre là
croyez-moi je l'ai relu et j'ai vérifié
chaque virgule
la première chose que j'ai faite c'est
de faire en sorte que le grand rabbin
soit informé de cette décision il est
informé et je crois d'ailleurs qu'il
nous écoute ce soir sur nous regarde ce
soir j'ai fait en sorte également que
Madame l'ambassadrice d'Israël à Paris
soit informé des démarches qui sont
effectivement prises par Dieudonné et
sur le plan religieux et sur le plan
politique tout le monde est au courant
depuis plusieurs semaines c'est ça moi
je le savais depuis deux trois mois je
vous en ai jamais parlé ici mais c'est
vrai que le choix le choix politique le
choix du journal de Monsieur Garmon
c'est que je lui ai dit que s'il y avait
une publication d'une demande de pardon
ça ne pouvait être que dans un journal
israélien et à partir d'un territoire
israélien ça c'est moi parce que je
considère que c'est tellement douloureux
et grave que c'est à partir d'Israël
qu'il fallait matérialiser ce pardon
c'est le pays on le sait à où on a voulu
mettre fin à 10000 2000 ans d'héran
cette souffrance et c'est à partir de là
et de cet endroit là que ça devait se
concrétiser donc j'ai eu mal de chiens
je vous dis tout de suite tout le monde
s'est dit oh là là parce que la question
qu'on se pose et que vous vous posez
tous c'est la suivante
est-ce qu'il est sincère et est-ce que
c'est pas une énième provocation
et qu'est-ce qu'il y a derrière ça
croyez-moi que j'ai vérifié Rev alors et
donc il est sincère il est effectivement
sincère il a totalement
il est pas il est pas dans une zone
bonne santé voilà j'ai pas d'éléments
supplémentaire à vous donner mais c'est
pas ça l'élément déclencheur l'élément
déclencheur c'est cette prise de
conscience à un moment donné la famille
aussi parce qu'il parle de ça c'est sept
enfants
ce que ça mène à rien que
l'antisémitisme ça ça a pas d'avenir ça
malheureusement a passé mais ça a pas
d'avenir alors les enfants les enfants
les enfants bah les enfants grandissent
et puis les enfants se disent qu'il y a
un décalage entre le dieu donné papa à
la maison et puis le Dieudonné sur scène
et que il y a quelque chose qui colle
pas donc on pose des questions on est
adolescents
et on est au cul du mur et on dit
maintenant que voilà ça suffit on peut
pas rire de tout voilà on peut pas rire
de tout et moi je quand j'ai fait ça que
j'ai travaillé ici c'est ces appels
téléphoniques ces démarches etc etc j'ai
croyez-moi j'ai j'avais toujours en tête
et ben tous les enfants petits enfants
de déportés alors je vous pose question
aussi que tout le monde se pose on a
l'impression qu'il va mettre fin à sa
carrière c'est ce que j'ai l'impression
de gagner dans la tête
je vais quitter la scène d'accord
c'est ça donc c'est un peu voilà non il
y a pas double langage il y a pas alors
non c'est pas un double langage c'est
c'est ça peut être une métaphore
que l'avenir est derrière lui
j'ai dit que je me faisais un point
d'honneur à vérifier que toutes les
condamnations ça exécutées payées parce
qu'on ne peut pas demander pardon et
avoir des dettes donc il ce qu'il doit
encore il va le payer il va le régler et
effectivement il faut qu'il le paie mais
il faut pas oublier de choses Quentin
Dieudonné il a pas de sens sur les mains
d'accord là-dessus
à ce point vous êtes habité par une
haine des Juifs vous ne savez pas si
derrière vous n'avez pas créé de
l'antisémitisme et des agressions dans
la rue pardon moi première chose la
phrase si vous avez bien lu la lettre
comment vous avez pu laisser la phrase
j'ai tenté de faire rire le monde
Juifs non il était habité dans les
interviews partout d'une haine des Juifs
il a pas tenté de les faire rire qu'ils
disent je les ai haïs je regrette mais
pas j'ai tenté de faire rire on ne fait
pas rire avec ce qu'il a fait mais
excusez-moi maître mais si vous me
mettez un mot un mot
ce qui nous a agité Dieudonné et moi à
une époque c'est que je lui dis que je
lui trouvais des ressemblances assez
extraordinaires avec son fana Fofana qui
était le celui qui a tué
ressemblances psychologiques c'est des
ressemblances et je rejoins
monsieur qui dit que effectivement il y
a des paroles qui peuvent tuer et des
paroles qui assassinent bien sûr faut
faire et c'est aussi ce qui m'a retenu
dans cette réflexion qui a pris une nuit
pour accepter de publier cette lettre
ma conclusion
c'est que la comparaison il faut fanas
c'est c'est vraiment une très mauvaise
comparaison je connais bien
chef
du Canada donc j'ai pratiqué Fofana donc
comparé Dieudonné il faut faire non tout
sauf ça deuxièmement qu'il est plus
qu'il ait pu effectivement déclencher
cette montagne du Grand Pardon fais-le
et j'ai l'impression que ce qui se passe
dans la tête de Dieudonné c'est qu'il se
dit qu'il veut retrouver la paix avec
lui-même et de dire voilà je vais
accepter de dire ce que je n'ai jamais
dit c'est que j'ai tort c'est que
j'aurais pas dû c'est que j'étais à
monstre et puis maintenant je demande je
demande pardon nous les ce qu'on avait
commencé à travailler
on avait travaillé sur que ce fait qu'on
était mort tous les deux et que
s'adressait à Dieu
et Dieu disait qu'est-ce que vous avez
branlé tu vois et chacun parlait c'était
donc sur le ton de la grosse rigolade
bien sûr le thème essentiel était de
réclamer le pardon quand on demande
facilement quand on demande pardon c'est
qu'on a des choses à se reprocher
d'accord
cette pardon ce pardon là on peut très
bien pas l'accepter en fait il demande à
ce qu'on lui tendre la main on lui tend
ou 8 ans pas alors on y croit c'est
juste ça et je pense qu'il le fait aussi
pour ces 7 enfants qui vont avoir son
nom et qui veut que ses enfants soient
tranquille plus tard mais je pense que
personne ne passe de la haine parce
qu'encore une fois il était habité
je veux dire une chose vous savez
peut-être raison vous avez peut-être
tort mais on n'a pas le droit de passer
à côté de ça c'est vrai parce que je
vais vous dire ça je sauf erreur de ma
part c'est la première fois depuis la
Shoah que quelqu'un demande pardon
peuple juif c'est la preuve
donnez-moi des exemples il y a beaucoup
de petits enfants mais oui vous savez ce
que je veux dire non je sais pas il y a
des petits enfants de de criminel nazi
qui sont aujourd'hui qui vivent
aujourd'hui en Israël ils sont même
devenus israéliens donc il y a beaucoup
de gens qui ont demandé pardon
mais alors Gilles Verdez
c'est la première fois que Dieu donnait
me touche et je n'ose pas croire
que ce ne serait pas une part de
sincérité il parle quand même de fautes
voilà j'espère que c'est sincère j'en ai
l'impression et je trouve qu'il va assez
loin et je trouve que c'est résilience
alors j'ai tellement critiqué lieu donné
que je me sens à l'aise pour dire
qu'aujourd'hui on peut pas refuser une
main qui est tendue comme ça de
quelqu'un qui a l'air vraiment désespéré
de ce qu'il a fait et je trouve que
cette prise de conscience de lieu donné
elle doit être salutaire pour tout ce
qu'on vit en ce moment tous les ans qui
ont des idées extrémistes tous les gens
qui respectent sa lettre à la fin
exactement il dit je suis persuadé que
le rire et la dérision un rôle à jouer
dans la restauration du lien de la
fraternité qui s'est rompue il faut
mettre l'humour au service des bonnes
causes
évidemment c'est extrêmement compliqué
parce que évidemment on connaît des gens
qui ont été absolument meurtris parce
qu'il a fait pendant des années Matthieu
évoquait le fait que sa parole portait
et donc elle a forcément eu des
conséquences pour les uns et les autres
peut-être qu'on n'oublie pas faurissons
qu'on n'oublie pas les faux déportés
qu'on n'oublie pas tous ces peines et
tous les gars qu'il a pu faire néanmoins
néanmoins et je suis juive je suis
toujours du côté du pardon donc parce
que je pense qu'on se grandit en
acceptant de pardonner à quelqu'un qui
demande et je peux comprendre en
revanche que d'autres n'arrivent pas
encore à faire cette démarche parce que
d'abord c'est extrêmement récent parce
que on a l'impression d'une soudaine t
on n'a pas vu une démarre beaucoup
des gens devant leur télé qui se disent
mais qu'est-ce qu'elle raconte pourquoi
elle lui pardonne tout de suite
maintenant comme ça et j'entends tout à
fait ceux qui disent pas tout de suite
pas maintenant ou jamais peut-être même
quelqu'un
aurait les 50 ans
juste à titre personnel quand quelqu'un
me tend la main j'ai envie de la saisir
en espérant évidemment qu'il ne me
manque pas mais je peux entendre ceux
qui ne veulent pas la saisir parce
qu'ils ont été tellement meurtri que
qu'il n'y arrive pas voilà mais
Jean-Michel c'est tellement énorme que
là j'ai même encore du mal à croire que
ce que j'entends
c'est qu'il soit gravement malade ce que
je n'espère pas évidemment et qui
veulent faire comme on le fait souvent
vider son sac avant de décéder et régler
ses comptes avec la société et faire une
introspection et reconnaître ses fautes
bon j'espère que c'est pas ça même si ça
serait quand même louable de faire ça
parce que en plus là c'est un suicide
artistique parce que évidemment les gens
qui la détestait qu'il a qu'il a
critiqué qu'il a sur lesquels il a vomi
ne vont pas vous venir voir ses
spectacles et ceux qui l'a entraîné dans
la haine ne vont se sentir trahi ils
vont punir je suis pas sûr que le recul
public de Dieudonné soit un public
d'antisémite
non je non je ne pense pas je ne fré
franchement jeunes pas quand on vient
voir un humoriste on vient pas parce que
on se fait plaisir dans la haine et on
rigole pas etc
qui dit que c'est le son public n'est
pas antisémite tu penses quoi je suis
entièrement d'accord avec lui je ben moi
j'ai vu quand même ainsi assis à côté de
de Laurent Ruquier de tout un tas les
deux premiers rangs au
québecueils de la mort il est déjà en
plein dedans mais non
son spectacle à domicile
[Musique]
il y a eu des erreurs plus que des
erreurs
un truc je suis d'accord avec Valérie
mais elle a parlé avec le fond de son
cœur il y a un truc qui est implacable
c'est que le pardon c'est la meilleure
chose à adopter c'est le pardon qui
donne le coup de sifflet final c'est pas
facile mais la personne qui vous parle
moi j'ai non non moi je me suis permis
par exemple de pardonner à l'assassin de
mon père bon c'est un peu terrible hein
mon frère se fait assassiner d'une
douzaine de coups de couteau et le mec
mon père essaye de fuir de la maison et
lui met le pied sur le dos et lui tire
un coup de carabine dans la nuque pour
le finir c'est assez fort quand même il
y a une vraie intention de nuire si tu
veux mais je peux te dire te jurer sa
tête de mes enfants que dans le box des
accusés cette personne était repentante
et lui ai pardonner parce que il
demandait pardon et l'eau tous les
autres scénarios tous les autres c'est
de la merde c'est du sourd c'est du feu
sur le feu bah c'est ce que fait Dieu
oui mais on n'est pas Dieu non non on
n'est pas Dieu mais moi je suis plus
près que toi
je le pense je pense d'ailleurs le quels
sont les enseignements catholiques ou
juifs les Juifs c'est la seule religion
qui préconise un jour pour le Grand
Pardon le Grand Pardon toujours
intéressant parce que même la démarche
par exemple de Jésus
Cyril après avoir raconté des idées
ignobles le dimanche de Jésus c'est quoi
c'est de dire à la personne qui le
reçoit ne laisse pas rentrer cette
prostituée dans la maison qu'est-ce que
dit Jésus dit dis donc toi quand je suis
arrivé chez toi tu va pas verser d'eau
sur les pieds comme ta religion le
préconise elle elle a la lavé mes pieds
avec ses larmes et les assécher avec ses
cheveux moi ça me touche au coeur le
pardon qui existe aussi dans la région
catholique
un dernier mot de André daron pour vous
vous l'avez vous pardonner vous
Dieudonné
écoutez d'abord la chose que je voudrais
dire et ça rejoint parce que dirige
Jean-Marie Bigard et notre ami l'avocat
c'est que maître du dos je crois mettre
Ludo c'est que les deux choses que j'ai
préconisé à Francis Lalanne de dire à
Dieudonné que je lui dirai demain c'est
effectivement c'est d'aller dans un sens
caritatif c'est la meilleure chose à
faire pour se faire pardonner c'est
d'aider les autres la réparation et et
la deuxième qui a été
préconisée par ma compagne et que j'ai
trouvé très intéressant et je ça rejoint
ce que disait Jean-Marie c'est de faire
parce que finalement tout est passé à
travers ses sketch tout à travers passer
à travers ton travail ben qu'il fasse
passer ce message de repentance de
repentir de contrition que j'ai dit à
travers un sketch à travers un spectacle
il faut que je trouve génial quoi donc
je viens d'apprendre le dernier mot je
voudrais savoir voix titre personnel ce
que vous en pensez ah c'est vrai alors
moi je vous dis ça fait des mois c'est
des semaines et puis on parle de ça j'y
croyais pas du tout mais je pense je
pense que c'est sincère je pense c'est
sincère après je sais pas dans quel but
ce qu'on il fait ça j'aimerais bien
savoir mais je pense que c'est sincère
après comme je vous l'ai dit est-ce que
c'est dans un but de se réhabiliter dans
les médias parce que c'est dans un but
pour protéger sa famille est-ce que
c'est dans un but vraiment parce qu'il
il a vraiment eu un une révélation il
s'est dit voilà tout ce que j'ai
d'ailleurs et qui c'est vraiment dans un
dans un c'est pas une révélation ça va
attendre cachot quand même hein
70 %
maître Ludo j'espère une chose j'espère
que c'est vrai parce que moi j'étais
j'ai fait plein d'émissions avec
Dieudonné à l'époque et voilà et c'est
vrai que après j'ai on a tous vu sa
transformation de la de dont il parle
même dans la lettre et c'est vrai qu'on
a pas compris et ça fait de la peine à
tout le monde ça fait de la peine à tout
le monde voilà donc on espère et
j'espère que c'est vraiment